I arrived in Moscow 1988 the earth
protests and even strikes in Moscow
because of a lack of soul matches and
other personal items when I was in
Moscow a few months ago outside my hotel
there was the single largest billboard I
have ever seen in my entire life and it
was for watches that I didn't even know
existed you know they were so Swiss that
they had holes in them it was
extraordinary and this is what Moscow
looks like this is the presence of the
rich and the super-rich in Moscow and I
mean downtown inside the Garden Room is
is amazing and we all know that it's not
the case and the provinces and a lot of
blah blah but the this is a startling
startling change the economic change is
different there are beautiful women
everywhere where did they come from
there are these kind of thuggish looking
men where did they come this all these
crazy questions come to the fore but
politically it's deeply depressing
deeply deeply depressing because what
you have an autocracy full stop that's
what you have you have this election is
no election it's a one-party state it's
kind of neo Soviet you know right now
there's a movement called naxi hours
which is a youth movement its opponents
relate to the Hitler jung-geun I don't
know if I'd go that far but it's
certainly not what we anticipated in
1991 not what one hope for tonight
you know you know III don't find that
there's access to the Kremlin right now
there's no access to the Kremlin except
on special occasions Time magazine
decides to make Putin Man of the Year
they comply with an interview and so on
but I think it's still for a foreign
reporter quite possible to get around a
lot find out allah the books that have
resulted David Hoffman's book for
example on the oligarchs versus fine a
piece of economic political reporting as
I've seen it's just the stories
radically different
my prediction for the election in March
2008 is that whatever Putin wants Putin
will get and what Putin seems to want is
to have Dmitry Medvedev become the
president and shock of all shocks Putin
will be his Prime Minister and I'm
guessing that'll be a rather suddenly
rather powerful prime ministership I
find that historical predicament for
Russia is such that it makes the
establishment of democracy incredibly
difficult but do I think there's
something in Russian genetic makeup or
blood that somehow mitigates against
democratic development no no any more
than I would think that that would be
the case of any other people the recent
years have shown that the desirable
conditions for the rise of democracy
have to do with the rise of the middle
class and and therefore middle class
comes to desire political normalcy and
political agency and all the rest there
is no doubt that I and millions of
others in 1991 watching fireworks go off
over the White House in Moscow were
naive to think that it would be a quick
and straight line to political democracy
you know I plead guilty to such
emotionally induced naivete but do I
think the only path is the path that's
happened no I don't believe that as a
historical festival
well where did they not go wrong I mean
I think beginning in 1993 with the
firing on the White House the wholesale
giveaway of Russian properties to
oligarchs for nothing the horrendous war
in Chechnya the installation of a KGB
oriented government in 2000 and so on